[Music]  so what are you doing out here there is  a legend in the jungles of the Amazon of  a tree that heals or it could change the  world but if it gets into the wrong  hands  he could awaken a great evil I believe  that the legend is real which was man  I'm gonna find it you are when I do  just imagine the lives that could be  saved I've been looking for this tree  longer than anybody I've tracked the  legend to every village every island  nothing researching for something that  can't be found but you've never had the  key let's do something that's safe  KUSI's of elephants there are no  elephants in the Amazon and I don't even  like elephants lady everybody likes  velvet  know this about the journal  everything that you see wants to kill  you and Canada  careful they could smell fear  [Music]  Oh My Goddess who brings a submarine to  the Amazon oh yeah  [Music]  goodnight  [Music]  forget it come on Frank  I don't got it that was a disaster go  the way I planned  [Music]  you